We've been talking a lot about Bernie Sanders
lately.
We've been talking a lot about Joe Biden and
how he fits into the 2020 democratic primary.
We talked yesterday on the bonus show about
how Beto O'Rourke has almost totally disappeared
from media coverage and his polling is down
as well from the eight to 12 range.
Beto is down to as low as 3% in two recent
polls, but what about Elizabeth Warren?
Warren is doing some really good stuff.
Warren is not only starting to get some headway
and positive feedback in Makkah country at
the events that she's been holding.
She's also pushed into the double digits in
a lot of recent polls and she's not doing
it with flash or charisma because as I've
said before, I don't find her particularly
rife with charisma or relate-ability, but
she's doing it with policy proposals that
are really interesting, many of which makes
sense.
Now, first of all, lots of right wingers have
been skeptical of Warren, some kind of anti
business, anti entrepreneurship type A and
she's really not.
So when she shows up and talks about letting
entrepreneurs and markets work in a controlled
way, that actually is having some appeal across
party lines, but she also has some really
specific and solid proposals that are strongly
socially democratic.
And this is a lot of the stuff I've been talking
about for years.
So let's look at some examples of Elizabeth
Warren's really great policy proposals.
Number one, antitrust.
Elizabeth Warren wants to pass legislation
that will require large tech platforms be
designated as platform utilities and get broken
apart or separated from a participants on
that platform.
She also, as part of her antitrust ideas,
would appoint regulators committed to reversing
illegal and anti competitive tech mergers,
really important.
And she talks about protecting the future
of the Internet, which is of course the importance
of net neutrality, really great stuff.
And I'm completely behind it.
She's also proposed an ultra millionaire tax,
and this would be a wealth tax on the richest
Americans and it would apply to households
with a net worth of over $50 million.
So this is only about 75 households, uh, in
a country of 340 million people, it's the
top 0.1%.
The way it would work is you pay a 2% tax
on every dollar of net worth, above $50 million
and a 3% tax on every dollar of net worth
above a billion.
Uh, this is expected to raise nearly $3 trillion
over a 10 year period.
Now, I do have a concern about this.
I'm unsure about this proposal, but it's a
specific proposal and I think it is fantastic
that Elizabeth Warren is talking really specifically.
My concern about the wealth tax is that a
lot of that net worth that people have on
paper is not liquid.
And I don't think it would be a good idea
to enforce attacks that might require rich
people to sell assets in order to pay the
wealth tax.
And, um, that's just kind of like a question
mark for me.
Uh, I also have other questions about whether
we should be focused on wealth or maybe looking
at capital gains more, more importantly, but
it doesn't matter, right?
Like my exact opinion on this idea doesn't
matter.
This is a very specific and ambitious proposal.
Um, universal childcare, the Universal Childcare
proposal that Elizabeth Warren has put out
there would see the government partner with
local childcare providers and childcare would
be free to anyone who is at 200% of the federal
poverty line or below.
Uh, and then if you are above 200% of the
federal poverty line, the cost of childcare
would be capped at 7% of income.
It would be paid for by the ultra millionaire
attacks that I just told you about.
Very interesting and important and there are
positive externalities of freeing up people
to go and work and earn wages that are good
for the government and they're good for those
families.
And it's a really interesting proposal.
Elizabeth Warren has a housing investment
plan, which she says we'll bring down rental
costs by 10% over 10 years and create a million
and a half jobs in construction and renovation.
It would see the government invest 500 billion
over the next 10 years to build, preserve,
and preserve and renovate units of housing
units, which will be affordable to low income
families.
This is textbook social democracy and she
would pay for it by a tweak to the estate
tax.
This is another very good proposal from Elizabeth
Warren.
You may remember that when George W. Bush
was in office, the first 7 million of an estate
were exempt from taxes.
That has been raised it to $22 million.
Elizabeth Warren would simply lower it back
to $7 million and uh, also, uh, tweak some
of the numbers in terms of the estate tax
rates for people who have really, really big
estates.
I can go on, there's many more of these proposals,
but this is a sampling and what is really
important to understand about this is that
Elizabeth Warren is not changing the capitalist
system that we have.
She's allowing entrepreneurship, she's allowing
business, she's allowing people to get very
rich and all of that stuff.
But she's saying we're going to use some of
that money to keep people from being left
behind.
We're going to have relatively modest government
involvement, a little more in line with some
of those Nordic and Scandinavian economies.
And these are serious specific proposals that
go way beyond what many other candidates are
doing or talking about.
So this is a substance over style approach.
It may not work, right?
I mean she's polling third or fourth depending
on the poll that you look at.
At a certain point, if she's going to be the
nominee, she needs to start making more headway
than she has.
And I don't know that this substance over
style approach will actually appeal to enough
people.
Biden's forward polling 40% uh, and he's so
far has been running almost exclusively on
Trump is bad and I will defeat him, which
I've pointed out is not a great way to run
a campaign.
Bernie, on the other hand is a more uh, in
line with the progressive ideas that people
are actually looking for when they are pulled
fairly about what they think government should
be doing.
And he's polling 14 to 18% depending on the
pole.
And Warren is putting out detailed policy
proposals that make a lot of sense and she's
pulling like seven to 12.
So I don't know that substance over style
is going to get you the nomination.
I don't know that if it gets through the nomination
that it will get you the presidency.
Very depressing unfortunately, but really
great that Elizabeth Warren is doing this.
And it is appealing to some voters who are
taking the
time to go to her town hall events and listen
to what she has to say.
Let me know what you think about her proposals
about this approach of the show is on Instagram
at David Tactic